consommer des messieurs ici je lis
drevet bienvenue à l'émission est-ce que
payer pour publiciser messages d'intérêt
public qui touchent des enjeux qui sont
abordés par des candidats en pleine
campagne électorale
c'est faire de la publicité électorale
il ya beaucoup de confusion actuellement
sur l'interprétation de la loi
électorale
en fait depuis quelques jours on voit
élections canada qui tente de calmer le
jeu qui fait quelques sorties mais
manifestement ça n'a pas réduit les
craintes de scientifiques
ils sont 350 avoir signé une lettre à
élections canada
une lettre qui s'adresse aussi aux chefs
des partis fédéraux pour demander des
clarifications
ce qu'ils craignent finalement c'est
d'être en quelque chose museler pendant
la campagne électorale
mais est ce que vraiment ce sont des
inquiétudes fondées
on va en parler avec un scientifique
vous le connaissez bien les souvent à
radio-canada souvent dans les médias
exige un grand directeur scientifique de
l'observatoire des sens et des
technologies de l'uqam ensemble gingras
bombay ce que vous partager leurs
inquiétudes
je dirais que non et il a raison et
qu'il faut distinguer puisqu'on parle de
projets très précis la question du
changement climatique et ont dit que ça
va être un enjeu électoral donc j'ai
relu une la loi parce qu'on en a à faire
assis ici à une l'encadrement juridique
tant que de loi se doit de définir des
balises de façon générale pour une
certaine mesure est donc un enjeu s'est
défini par l'action sociale on peut pas
définir à l'avancé que sur ces points
dangereux que ce soit donc quand on dit
oui 2 2 font 5 ça pourra pas être un
enjeu
il n'y a pas de choses que ça arrive sur
mais dire que le réchauffement est
plutôt le dérèglement climatique est un
enjeu ce n'est pas dire qu'il n'existe
pas s'est séparé le fait que le
consensus scientifique mais ensuite il
ya un débat social et politique sur les
actions à mener une option distinguer
mieux l'affirmation purement
scientifique de l'état de la
connaissance des actions qui sont
toujours multiples on se sait que
citerai pas trop surtout les
scientifiques comme un division 2 on
doit leur dire sans aucune ambiguïté qui
peuvent continuer à dire tout ce qu'ils
ont à dire de scientifiques parce que la
loi dit expressément qu'ils peuvent
comme individu diffusée sur une base non
commerciales dont ils ne payent pas les
investissements comme des groupes
d'action qui eux ont des enjeux ont des
idéologies ont des convictions
ils doivent ils peuvent émettre
d'opinion ils peuvent diffuser des
riou des débats des discours des
nouvelles des entrevues des commentaires
des lettres donc comme moi ici je peux
venir dire que ceux qui nient le
réchauffement climatique sont des
ignorants
j'ai le droit de dire je vais toujours
le dire par contre accepté le climat et
dire ensuite est-ce qu'il faut fermer
des usines
est-ce qu'il faut développer des
nouvelles technologies pour absorber le
carbone les puits de carbone soit c'est
un débat qui discutaient gens même plus
loin il ya des gens qui vont dire au
québec que ça se réchauffe c'est bon
pour le vin rouge
on peut être en désaccord ne s'est pas
mouillé le changement climatique dont il
ya beaucoup de confusion dans la lettre
lorsqu'ils disent que considérer que
c'est un que le réchauffement climatique
est un enjeu c'est déjà de remettre en
cause
pas du tout c'est dire au contraire
c'est un enjeu pour dire qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire agir plus vite et agiront et
bien ça c'est un débat social le
scientifique dit sur 400 parties par
million c'est pas une bonne idée comparé
à 250 parties par million dont se mettre
dessus ou deux mais de d'autres types de
gaz comme l'ammoniac l'outil c'est que
la loi elle vous empêche pas vous
scientifique de parler elle vous empêche
pas de m'accorder une entrevue ce soir
par exemple même si les élections
étaient déjà déclenché mais il ya des
gens que ça inquiète et en cours entre
autres des groupes environnementalistes
qui eux aussi se font sur la science
leurs prétentions pour faire passer un
message qu'il trouve d'intérêt public
par exemple quand il parle des
changements climatiques qui veulent
faire de la sensibilisation là-dessus
même pendant la campagne électorale et
pour diffuser leurs messages
oui ils peuvent accorder des entrevues
mais peuvent aussi payer pour faire
rayonner leurs messages par exemple dans
les réseaux sociaux en sait beaucoup
comme ça aujourd'hui
eux ils disent bien écoutez maintenant
ça va être vu comme étant la publicité
électorale est ce que eux ont raison de
s'inquiéter
donc je pense qu'ils ont eu tort de
s'inquiéter parce qu'il ya un document
d'ailleurs quelques parures de deux
jours d'une association de juristes de
la côte ouest des juristes de
l'environnement qui ont dit que c'est
une exagération il faut lire
attentivement ce qui est écrit
parce que confirmer par tous même si on
paye des annonces pour dire que 2 2 font
4 c'est la science mais le danger des
groupes environnementaux souvent quand
je les observe et analyse jour du
secours c'est qu'ils font et glisse mais
entre la vérité scientifique
le consensus scientifique et les actions
politiques à mener par exemple tout le
débat sur la question de la production
du pétrole
c'est pas une question scientifique
parce que les ceux qui produisent du
pétrole pourra dire on travaille sur les
technologies pour absorber l'équivalent
d'un carboneutre mais ça fera peut-être
pas la faire de plus de tout le monde
car mon honneur
il faut bien distinguer la science vous
voyez l'action finalement de ces groupes
comme greenpeace comme davantage du
militantisme
oui ce que vous faites pas avec votre
conscience afin qu'ils relèvent qui
relève de la science et qui voit plus
loin par exemple dans les dettes des 356
scientifique il faut bien dire qu'elle
est toute fin il demande
élections canada d'admettre que le
changement climatique est un phénomène
non partisan mais c'est un pur de
demander sur pourquoi
élections canada c'est quoi sa fonction
sociale c'est de s'assurer d'être le
gardien de la loi donc lui si une
plainte
ils vont regarder il a bien dit que vous
pourriez devoir vous inscrire il
applaudit vous allez devoir vous avertis
à l'avancé selon ce que vous allez dire
il se pourrait que vous tombiez sous la
coupe de la loi si son travail mais ce
qui est gérée si vous êtes précis ce qui
inquiète aussi mathieu gingras ce que
élections canada quand il définit où
sont ces balises là dedans et vous savez
les enjeux que paul est déterminé à
l'avancé parce que les enjeux ils vont
être imposées par les candidats
eux-mêmes alors en l'occurrence
changement climatique semaine maxime
bernier un qui est reconnu comme étant
et le film d'ailleurs comme étant un
climato sceptiques
est-ce qu il pas un risque ici par
exemple si un candidat dit
les vaccins c'est dangereux ça rend
malade alors pendant salle on a des
groupes même de santé publique qui font
de la promotion pour les vaccins et qui
ont droit d'utiliser des informations
les étudiants eux mouvement vous pensez
pas qu'il risque d'être assujetti
justement à cette particularité de la
loi électorale
est-ce que leur message risque d'être
reconnus comme de la publicité
électorale en cas d'élection si j'étais
eux je me poserai possession
interviendra en dire écoutez en tant que
scientifique toutes les études et de
l'association raison pour la promotion
du vaccin oms ni les scientifiques les
études denéchaud montre que le vaccin
diminue les risques de x y z points je
réponds plus loin je nommerai pas aucun
parti je dirais voici ce que la science
dit et ensuite j'aimerais bien voir si
une plainte qui va être faite et qu'elle
soit la conclusion d'élections canada
donc les scientifiques doivent se dire
nous
on doit être complètement libre
d'intervenir comme on veut mais pour
parler de sciences pour pour dire qu'il
veut produiront un pétrole c'est pas la
sienne à l'absence et non pas des moyens
exactement les moyens sont multiples
sont débattus dans la société et ce
n'est pas de la science et on pense que
la science nous fait conclure à écrire
etc si on a bien compris monsieur
gingras que peut-être pas un des
signataires de la lettre mais vous avez
posé votre regard de scientifiques sur
ce positionnement
d'autres scientifiques merci de nous
avoir expliqué jean serrat plaisir